The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah.
I taught fourth grade and now those kids are grown up and that's really cool
because some of them told me it was the best year of their lives.
They come to see me do stand up.
Oh,
that's amazing.
Very cool.
Will you teach and what worth it took everything but fourth grade is different
than science.
Everything.
I mean,
yeah,
it's different than what you did because you went to people who had an interest
and a love for something and wanted to explore it what you were doing.
But mine is different.
They had to be there.
So my thing was self doubt,
self esteem.
I figured I can't teach them.
These subjects are going to come and go in their lives,
but teaching them self esteem and some of the most rewarding things were like
had this one kid,
he was real shy,
so shy.
He was real tall and he was embarrassed by it and he would stay in the.
In the cloak room,
they'd call it a,
you know,
we're all the coats and you just stay in there.
It will come out.
I go,
Sky Come,
Sky King because he was a space cadet goes sky,
you got to come out,
they can't stay,
I can't let a kid just sit and,
you know,
and by the end of me just like work in his self esteem and all,
he was in the middle of the class,
just what everybody else waving his hand and his mother came up to me and she
was like really touched by it and told me that I changed his life and,
and you know,
that kind of Shit's cool.
And now I got like a couple of the girls come to see me and she goes,
one of the girls goes,
uh,
ms.dot,
dot,
dot dot.
Why did you let us do so much stuff?
You know,
like I said,
because you were smarter than me.
I said,
she got to me.
look,
you know,
I,
I had more knowledge because I was an adult.
But you know,
kids,
lot of you have more brainpower to me.
Maybe.
I know I wasn't smart enough to know that I wasn't,
that's why you ran the class.
You know what I mean?
So you were an easy teacher.
That's what he talks easy.
I told them at the beginning of the year,
I said,
look,
I want this to be the most fun year of your life.
Only you can mess it up.
Fucking awesome opportunity.
That must have been.
And I said,
I want to go to the gym.
This is one.
I was playing basketball.
I said,
I want to go to the gym more than you do,
so we're going to have a party.
Every Friday afternoon we'd have.
We'd have like kids that would do break dancing and stuff and really?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
That was great.
Did you ever try to pitch that as a sitcom a no,
but somebody else had an idea for a couple of times with be hilarious Sitcom.
It seems like a natural.
Yeah.
You as a.
As a a funny teacher because you really did it.
It's legit and if you really stop and think about it,
that would be like for a kid that's like one of the greatest rolls of the dice
have kicked and get for their fourth grade teacher.
I had a girl for your fourth grade teacher.
She still calls me Mr Herrera.
She was 26 years old or whatever.
He calls me Mr Herrera.
Right.
And I go,
Theresa,
first of all,
you're taller than me.
She's always hot blonde.
I go start with the Mr. you can call me dumb.
She because I just can't call you dumb net.
Funny.
She's got got me down as Mr Herrera.
That's good.
That'll keep you from being a dirty bird.
Whoa,
whoa.
Stay away dog.
She's a little girl.
Let her talk call you.
Ms Dot Darwish.
Trying to establish boundaries.
Somebody said,
why do you feel young?
I go,
because I can come on.
Do you think that becoming more aware or reaching a higher state of
consciousness because of your experiences will actually help you because it'll
abandoned a lot of the distractions that you present yourself almost
unknowingly.
Yeah.
Well,
it helps me.
It helps me in training and particularly when I'm running now because I used to
listen to like Pantera and disorder when I was running and I worked myself into
like a rage so I would run into exhaustion.
That was kinda how I trained and I trained all the way through my career like
that and the last couple of fights,
so sweet stuff.
I listened to a lot more like,
like more like buying binaural beat type of stuff when I'm running so I could
get into more like a meditative stage,
you know,
doing a lot of yoga as well and trying to find the same thing where you just,
you,
you're within yourself and you're not focusing on anything else.
So your body's almost like on autopilot.
Yeah.
That the music that you listened to when you train can have a profound effect on
my approach.
Your training.
Yeah.
It really can.
It's so important and that's why I've always been so vocal about all this stuff
I listen to like I'd like training camp playlist,
so I tweet everyday trump songs I was listening to and that kind of thing is
important.
And,
and,
and the other thing as well,
like earlier on in my career,
I would use music to anchor feelings.
So like,
like,
uh,
when I fought Ludwig I used the song called Ian by Woodkid,
which was the first time I'd switched it from Angola belongs to me for like,
you know,
a bunch of fives.
Um,
so like for the 12 weeks of that fight I was training with Frank Mir,
we were going up to read it,
it's up to Mount Charleston and now into red rock and like doing hill running
and stuff.
And we had some real tough sessions.
I mean,
you know,
we're ready to put ourselves through for that training camp and as soon as I got
back in my truck,
after the session,
if I felt like it was a good session that was productive and I felt positive,
I would put that song on and I would say I would constantly connect those
feelings to that song.
So then when,
when I'm walking out and that song comes on immediately I get that feeling
again.
Huh.
You know?
And it's just like,
you know,
just like when you listen to a sermon,
you think of a person like,
oh,
I heard that someone was with that person and you made that connection
immediately.
But you can also train yourself to do it.
Yes.
That's why you like allison to Cypress Hill now.
And it will take me back to fighting in cage warriors like back in 2006.
Wow.
And I have songs all the way through like that and now I don't listen to because
it was like my first two fights.
I came back to Pantera,
drag the waters.
By the time I got to the cage I was so wound up and so angry that I was just run
out of gas immediately.
And now whenever I listened to those songs,
I get that feeling of like exhaustion,
like ugh.
And I look at what's out there.
Some answers make no sense to me and they seem to lead down really unhealthy
path.
So thank you.
But no thanks.
Are there answers?
Make more sense or maybe eight aunt and like I'm happy with my own,
but as bad it really boiled down to the but mostly researcher and experience,
a rejecting what is useless and absorb what is useful and what specific or
you're on,
you know,
he's as you can make the dollar tree for Alpha approach knowledge.
I mean,
he applied it to martial arts,
but he's a brilliant way of approach.
Just any kind of knowledge,
whether it's already.
It's about life.
Yeah.
That's hard for people to accept that.
Right.
It's um,
it's much easier to follow the pattern that your family's from Holland.
I'm a Lutheran because grandma's Lutheran grandpa always said that no matter
what,
we will be Lutherans.
Yep.
I remember talking to this girl and uh,
she said that she was going to get a tattoo of a cross.
And I said,
uh,
I said,
oh,
I go,
you're really religious.
She goes,
well,
not really,
but you know what?
I was born Catholic and I figured out that no matter what,
that's the one thing that'll be for the rest of my life.
What the fuck?
I mean,
and I remember saying I don't like,
you know,
I didn't know her very well,
so I was like,
okay,
um,
how do you know,
like,
how do you know you won't change your mind about that?
She's like,
Oh my God,
my family would kill me.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
Well good luck with that.
Good luck with that.
Wow.
Yet at war,
war gone different.
There will be people.
Today's a really nasty,
but you know,
if I don't put the trust account,
my grandma would have.
Her feelings will get really hurt and so it's,
I don't hate the Jews,
but grandma fucking hates Jews and I love grandma know.
It's like I don't want to make them sad.
You know what's hilarious is that she was going to get a Catholic tattoo in the
first place because like in the Bible it very specifically says,
so like getting a religious attitude was like,
well,
you're not listening to me.
No,
only what I listened when it's convenient,
but across tattoo is so sexy.
It makes me spiritual and it thins out my back.
And that's the other point of the people get peace when you are cutting you at
all and he's like,
what do you create your own?
It's not.
There are some absolute truths that fall from heaven when they stop people that
are making up their own sheet anyway.
I mean,
when people say a full time thing is bullshit,
they are making up their own thing because they.
We'll add some powers that they don't like.
They will focus on the day like and but at the end that it's the one and only
interpretation and say if you're going to do that,
might as well be honest and just peek from any source.
If you're going to pick and choose.